et comme tous les lundis du sport et
comme tous les lundi on retrouve Anthony
histoire Anthony Catherine bienvenue
dans ce dernier 7 8 sport de la saison
une édition spéciale Tour de France
alors que vient tout juste de se
terminer la troisième étape entre
Ajaccio et Calvi emporter par
l'Australien Simone Garance nous allons
nous projeter un peu plus tard vers la
21e et ultime étape de 700e édition qui
se déroulera entre Versailles et les
Champs-Élysées le 21 juillet prochain et
puis évidemment en fin d'émission tous
les résultats du week-end Catherine
voilà mais on commence effectivement par
ce Tour de France qui va passer à
Saint-Quentin quel événement le 21
juillet prochain le peloton terminera
700e grande boucle avec une étape longue
de 133 km 500 entre Versailles et les
Champs-Élysées je le disais et les
acteurs de cette étape certains acteurs
sont avec nous je veux bien sûr parler
de de Monsieur Cadalbert le président de
la Communauté d'Agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonsoir à vous
et vous êtes accompagné d'un jeune
cycliste prometteur Xavier Avenel qui
est licencié au Vélo Club d'Élancourt de
50 ans en Yvelines bonsoir à toi bonsoir
alors je le disais cette étape va être
un peu unique déjà puisqu'on va passer
on va partir de Versailles traverser
toute l'agglomération pour finir sur les
Champs-Élysées de nuit c'est déjà en soi
une étape presque exceptionnelle non
c'est exceptionnel mais pour nous le
vélo c'est pas exceptionnel et c'était
normal que on fasse en sorte que le Tour
de France passe par le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin Centre national du
cycliste qu'on va effectivement
inaugurer à la fin de l'année et d'avoir
cette étape mythique entre Versailles et
les Champs-Élysées forcément ils vont
passer par la minière ils vont aller du
côté de challenger à Guyancourt tout ça
repartir sur Montigny devant le
Vélodrome pour repartir en voyant ses
amateurs de vélo passer devant la stèle
japonais
et puis par Manille et toute le circuit
des des labels chevreuses et repartir
par manie tout ça pour nous c'est un
circuit mythique du vélo et de devenir
de fait la capitale du vélo en France
surtout avec sa centre national et le
Vélodrome et quelque chose de
fondamental d'important comme l'aide
depuis plus de 20 ans le Paris-Brest
Paris qui est la plus grande épreuve de
cyclotourisme donc on a et le Tour de
France qui est de fait la première
épreuve mondiale de vélo sur route et le
Paris-Brest qui est la première épreuve
mondiale de cyclotourisme il faut le
rappeler le Tour de France c'est diffusé
dans 190 pays un pendant trois semaines
au niveau des droites télévisuels et ce
parcours est-ce que vous avez joué un
rôle justement vous êtes dit il y a le
vélodrome on veut que le tracé fasse un
petit détour puisque sur cette dernière
étape le tracé fait un petit détour
justement par la Communauté
d'Agglomération
tous les ans pratiquement le Tour de
France passe à saint-quentin-en-vime à
manier et hameau il faut le rappeler
donc il passe à manier un mot là
effectivement il y a un parcours
particulier qu'on a voulu avec les
organisateurs du Tour de France avec la
Fédération Française pour passer devant
le vélodrome qui sera le siège le
la Fédération Française de cyclistes et
le Centre national du cyclisme les
jeunes vont être pouvoir avoir tous les
outils pour devenir des vrais champions
ils sont déjà mais là ils auraient pu
d'excuses pour effectivement les Jeux
Olympiques 2024 ils seront au top mais
ça veut dire qu'il y aura des travaux
qui vont être fait pour le pour
améliorer le bitume pour le passage non
pas ça non c'est bon
bien sûr on a fait attention surtout
pour les problèmes de travaux puisque on
est en travaux pour effectivement faire
de l'accès entre le Vélodrome et la gare
puissent être finissent la venue du pas
du lac mais on a surtout fait attention
à ce que pour le 21 juillet là tout le
monde sera effectivement amené à
regarder passer non seulement le Tour de
France mais aussi toute la caravane du
Tour de France à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans cette
étape mythique de Versailles à Paris
cette 21e étape on le rappelle va passer
d'abord par Guyancourt évidemment le
départ de Versailles puis
Montigny-le-Bretonneux devant le vélo
drone on repart sur sur voisin le
Bretonneux puis manileamo où il y a
cette stèle Jacques antique qui sera
sûrement peut-être à ce moment un petit
peu émotion côté histoire de cette étape
oui mais encore une fois il passe
régulièrement tous les ans
de Chevreuse à manier un mot à la stèle
j'attend-il je dirais que c'est presque
tradition par contre pour passer devant
le vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est vrai que
c'est très première et je pense que tous
les amateurs de vélo seront contents de
voir comment l'investissement national
régional de la France et de
l'agglomération pour la promotion du
vélo et que les jeunes aient des outils
à la hauteur de leurs ambitions comme
les Grégory Baugé n'a pas été champion
olympique et que médailles d'argent
peut-être parce qu'il y avait pas les
outils d'entraînement qu'il aurait
maintenant c'est souvent ce qu'il disait
d'ailleurs pendant pendant ces
compétitions planter autour du Vélodrome
là il y a une petite déco prévue pour
l'instant non non pas de déco parce que
d'une part il est pas terminé la piste
est même pas encore montée c'est tout
l'espèce extérieur le 12 août sur ces
cinq villes traversées ça fait donc une
par une bonne partie de cette étape sur
sur l'agglomération comment on organise
le trajet le passage du Tour de France
il y a des axes fermés comment ça se
passe donc ce trajet a été choisi par
les ordinateurs avec les services de la
préfecture et des villes pour permettre
effectivement la pleine sécurité du
passage du Tour de France et de sa
caravane qui est forcément c'est d'abord
les problèmes de sécurité qui qui
l'emportent et après bien sûr le les
routes seront fermées à partir de 3
heures mais vous aurez des panneaux
partout vous arrivez petites affiches
sur le tournage passage du Tour de
France qui sera comme celle-ci vous
l'avez en scoop la première et c'est là
bien sûr et c'est ça qui est important
pour nous c'est de faire que ce 21
juillet soit un jour de fête du vélo sur
toute la dernière étape en général c'est
pas une course à part sur les
Champs-Élysées c'est surtout une parade
des des coureurs qui ont fait
effectivement ont atteint la dernière
étape parce que il faut à l'atteindre
on a l'impression que depuis quelques
années le vélo est devenu un petit peu
le mode de transport à la mode enfin de
compte un petit peu et avec tous les
espaces qu'il y a sur sa canton de
Yvelines c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
propice ici non le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est
relativement plat c'est bien des
problèmes Xavier
et c'est vrai que les propices au
déplacement en vélo on a fait de
nombreux kilomètres de piste cyclable on
continue à avoir un programme avec la
région de développement de ces pistes
cyclables et aussi on organise on vient
de voter jeudi un projet de plan local
déplacement et dans lequel il y a un
syndrome de vélos station qui sont
importantes que les pistes cyclables et
donc on continue cette objective de
faire en sorte qu'il y a beaucoup plus
de gens qui puissent dans de bonnes
conditions et d'avoir des conditions de
sécurité prendre leur vélo pour se
déplacer pour revenir sur le tracé et
sur cette étape Xavier tu auras un rôle
un petit peu particulier le 21 juillet
on va en parler juste après ce sujet si
tu veux bien deux semaines en fait avant
le départ du Tour les villes étables de
la 100e édition de la Grande Boucle
proposait aux amoureux du vélo de
parcourir une partie du tracé de l'étape
que feront les professionnels dans
quelques jours nous avons découvert la
dernière justement entre Versailles et
les Champs-Élysées avec Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude
en voyant ces amateurs de vélo passer
devant la stèle Jacques Anquetil en haut
de la côte de château fort on s'imagine
déjà le 21 juillet lorsque le peloton du
Tour de France traversera le parc du
château de Versailles avant l'arrivée
finale en nocturne sur les sciences
Élysées avec la journée à chacun son
étape ses cyclistes ont pu se glisser
dans la peau des professionnels pour
quelques kilomètres
important pas forcément mais c'était un
d'ailleurs on pourra se dire j'ai fait
au moins une quasiment à l'étape l'étape
du Tour c'est cycliste amateurs ont mis
en moyenne près de trois heures pour
parcourir les 87 km proposés par le
conseil général entre Versailles et le
Trocadéro avec 800 mètres de dénivelé
positif longue de 133 km cette dernière
étape ne sera pas de tout repos pour les
coureurs c'est un peu casse pas quand
même quelques quelques bonnes côtes
et notamment c'est la l'arrivée là au
niveau de la côte des gardes avec le
petit radar qui qui du bien son homme
pour que la fête soit parfaite les
amoureux du vélo pouvaient croiser ici
ou là des anciennes gloire du peloton ça
a redonné un petit peu le sens de la
fête du Tour de France qui est toujours
une fête le Tour de France parce que on
le voit par tout ce qu'il a encouru tout
ce qu'il a passé ça reste toujours une
fête populaire on a toujours le monde et
en faisant des manifestations comme ça
je crois que c'était une belle journée
réussie une fête que tout le monde n'a
pas pu vivre à la demande de la
préfecture de Paris les organisateurs
ont dû revoir leur prétention à la
baisse seul les 250 premiers inscrits
sur 1200 demandes ont pu ainsi prendre
la route vers Paris